she comes to my show and she uh
tried to hook up basically I think she
likes to try to like turn straight women
[Music]
I'm Rachel Feinstein I'm here to answer
the internet who is the hottest
celebrity you'd have a chance with if
they got to know you maybe like a chef I
feel like I could maybe bag a chef
because they're like a little like a lot
of chefs are like a little unstable and
they do a lot of blow yeah like Guy
Fieri yeah I feel like I could bag him
maybe he would like let me give him a
handy or something
would you rather
oh uh watch your dad [ __ ] a hundred year
old man
um
or watch your mother kill someone
I definitely watch my mom kill somebody
because I could kill like yeah I could
just have her kill some douche or
something yeah definitely
that even that question is gonna bother
me like that's gonna haunt me later
because your mind like it creates quick
little pop-ups and then I just had my
dad just this that's not good I did a
joke once and I and my dad's very
supportive and he comes out to like my
shows and stuff and I said I know and
it's so embarrassing I said the phrase
mediocre hand job and made accidental
eye contact with my father it was one of
the most traumatizing moments in my life
because he was really supporting me too
he's like yeah
here for you oh he's jerking off to
webcam girls cheating yes I would file
it in that yeah yeah I mean I'm I just
imagine that
um whatever is happening on any guy's
computer is just like absolutely vile
yeah just that you're just spraying
vileness until yeah so but yeah that's
not an image I would want to think about
yeah would you rather have a chef
masseuse or chauffeur for the rest of
your life
um definitely a chauffeur because I like
to I Uber everywhere I like Chariot
myself around I'll take an Uber to the
gym like it's hauntingly short distances
you know like I'm actively ashamed of my
Uber history yeah it'll be like a four
minute ride it's like who are you you
pig but I'm always running late so you'd
rather just have one driver yes a driver
they'll be amazing I would love a driver
exactly yeah and he never has to know I
mean nobody ever has to know if you
could [ __ ] anyone you wanted and they'd
die immediately after
who would you pick that's such an
interesting question you know who I
think is really hot like um I can't
think of the name but you guys would
definitely know if you guys know sports
but I like I find like those emotionally
unavailable like um Angry coaches that
are kind of pacing on the sideline
really attractive there's a lot of them
and you just looked at me like with
genuine concern you're like oh dear you
know the football players are too
obvious you know what I mean like I
don't want to be in that long line you
know but the kind of the coach is always
like a little pissed off just like looks
stressed you know even when his team's
doing well you're like this guy never
really has a real moment of Happiness
um and there's like a few of them that I
actually find kind of attractive
um but I don't know their names do you
like what you want to [ __ ] like Bill
Belichick yeah like Bill Belichick yeah
and then because I feel like he can't be
that nice of a guy you know I'm not
saying I want to kill him but I'm like
if one were to die maybe you know
him rather than um
I love it I find them very attractive
like but they're just like staring at
clipboard like a little kind of tense
about something I don't understand in
the first place yeah they're perfectly
unavailable if a guy matches with his
best friend's sister on Tinder should he
pursue it why not I mean it's not what
life's for
huh
I don't know would you rather your mom
or daughter be a porn star definitely my
mom obviously yeah I mean because then
it's you know at least it's a wrap it's
less harmful maybe she's enjoying it at
that point yeah what about if your
daughter was like a
very successful only fans girl
every daughter was just by herself
there's no one my daughter's like 14
months now could we go through these
potential scenarios 150 Grand a month
I'd rather not like reckon with what
type of potential porn I feel
comfortable with her doing also when I
was on Last Comic Standing somebody
found some porn that like where the girl
looked just like me and it like went all
over the Internet everybody was watching
thinking that it was me and it did look
a lot like me and then somebody was like
Last Comic laying down or whatever and
everybody's like we found her she does
porn and my mom went on Twitter I was
like writing back to everybody you know
she got her own account and was like
that's my daughter and it's not true
she's not sucking anybody off would you
rather have no music for the rest of
your life or have all music be sung by
your significant other oof no music yeah
he can't I mean and I really like I'm
constantly like playing stuff all the
time but he um yeah he really stinks
definitely there have been times where
I'm like oh I'll put out tonight and
then I'm like I hear him humming
something and I'm real grossed out real
gross sometimes when he's cleaning like
um hip-hop to himself like [ __ ]
and I'm like who is the one person in
the world you would least want to bang
you at least want to bang your
significant others I'll give you that
that's
I like that it's constantly just up in
the air whether I'm a complete idiot or
not that one I'll give you generally
you're a real dummy who's the one person
in the world you at least want to bang
your significant other I'm trying to
think a hard one can you guys help me I
guess maybe like uh I can't help you
Jenna Jameson okay can I choose Jenna
James and say yes because I feel like
she did just a really good job and you'd
see that I've been phoning it in all
along he's like this is a hand job yeah
I mean I'm a real ass like right after
he comes I'll be like that's not the
amount we agreed upon like I'm always
just a you know a jackass so I mean
he'll be like I'd like a real experience
rather than you know like you're like a
clown I did get a Catholic school girl
outfit to like surprise him because I
was like oh I figure that's what
Catholic guy is like I don't know but
I'm
would you rather your husband be able to
read your thoughts during sex or all the
time except during sex
I mean I think I'd be fine with like sex
it's usually just I assume like the same
images a guy has in his brain just like
a series of quick foul things that don't
have that much to do with him you know
would you rather wake up in the middle
of the night to see a massive dude has
broken into your house sorry I can't
read so this takes me a little longer um
or to see a ghost
I mean definitely a ghost this is a
ridiculous question a massive dude
that's going to do active and immediate
harm to me or like it could be some
Victorian Elder sewing in the corner
yeah obviously yeah
that one would you rather somebody you
know hurl towards you and it actively
assault you
yeah you see like a lady with a brooch
in the corner yes obviously the brooch
broad I feel like ghosts are you know
actually Jenna Jameson told me this
because she came to one of my shows Once
and yes you've had like interactions
with Jenna Jameson she came I have a
whole story about him I special because
she came to my show in Buffalo and they
were like um uh my agent called me he
was like Jenna Jameson wants to come to
your show tonight and I'm like the porn
star and he's like yeah like why is she
in Buffalo why am I in Buffalo actually
well I have you on the phone but so then
I she comes to my show and she uh
tried to hook up basically I think she
likes to try to like turn straight women
yes [ __ ] so she came to the show first
of all it made my life seem so much
cooler than it really is because usually
when I get to my Green Room there's like
maybe like a few sunflower seeds and
like a do-rag like they know what I'm
worth you know and uh it's pretty empty
in there it's like a dead man's own and
so all these guys were in in the Green
Room you know pretending they're there
to like support my show but they were
just like horny and backed up and wanted
to meet Jenna Jameson this is like the
most exciting thing that's happened in
Buffalo and like what years yeah this
was like
um like eight years ago or something and
she was very hot she was the kind of hot
where like it's not safe like you know
men are just coming everywhere people
are slipping and falling and stuff and I
was like getting ready for my date with
Jenna Jameson I was like what should I
wear you know I figured like she'd
probably have like you know one of those
dresses you buy at a dildo store just
like a plastic dildo dress or something
and um all I had were like Paula
Poundstone like stand-up Blazers
and uh I just had a lot of corduroy
dense Blazers and so I come downstairs
and she was just in my hotel and she
wanted to pick me up and she was like
you and me a life on the road she's one
of those little girl voices that guys
like and it was so weird I'm like you
sound like a six-year-old the guy's like
yes you are like it's so weird
and I just really realized I wasn't at
all a Woman by hanging out with her like
because the like level of attention she
would get you know like yeah and she
would take selfies with me and she knew
all her like hot like selfie angles and
I just kind of became more and more
manly and like I just started sort of
guarding the picture like spitting on
the grounds and stuff
and then one of the guys was like are
you a fan of Rachel's and she was like I
want to have sex with her and I I
couldn't handle that at all so I uh you
ever like nervous you have a voice come
out of you and you're just like what was
that I was like calm down Jenna I
sounded like a Scottish sailor or
something and the guys loved this whole
scenario where she was like trying to
get me to have sex with her and I was
like even if I'm gonna have sex with a
girl it's not gonna be Jenna James like
I've never hooked up with a girl but I'm
like I can't that's like a porn legend
you know like yeah no like really and
I'm like an [ __ ] after sex like I
like I'll throw change on my husband so
like I'm a [ __ ] I can't throw coins
on Jenna Jameson you know so then we go
to this she kept having these like
little
um like appointments with me during the
night she's like we gotta talk like you
know I'm like okay Diana and then
is at the bar in Buffalo and I mean like
after the comedy show she's like you're
there's eyes your party in the bar but
she'll pull you aside and be like we
gotta talk yeah she kept being mad at me
like it was weird like I don't know you
at all she's like boo hey my man and I I
just kept doing everything she told me
to do I don't know why I guess I guess I
for I guess I figured it'd be a good
story I was like I'll do everything she
tells me to do before it's time to
scissor and then I'm out I'll do
everything like pre-scissoring I was
like I'll do it sure you know I just
kept doing and also she's the kind of
hot where even if you're not attracted
to her you just start like obeying her
you know because like I could see for a
moment what it must feel like to be a
guy that needs to get laid you're just
like a video game maybe where you're
like tunneling towards ass and you deal
with like annoying [ __ ] you're like oh
there's that Dragon thing I have to
[ __ ] play you just like handle
annoyances and you're like oh God that
troll I hate this bridge with that troll
thing you know so um but yeah anyway at
the end of the night
she was like um you know are you gonna
come over and and then she said our
hotel is haunted which I thought was the
most brilliant way to get a girl to come
over and just sit on your face just act
like there's some like evil ghosts but
we can scissor them gone together
so that's how she got was like trying to
get me to come over and um and uh I I
was like I can't like I can't I can't go
have a seance with Jenna James it was
too much so I was like uh I don't think
I can do that
um you know but maybe we'll you know
keep in touch or I'll text you I'm kind
of tired I don't know what my excuse was
for
not uh coming over and then she was like
don't worry most ghosts are just like
you know people that miss their families
and
places
just because but it was a very
compassionate stance on the most
buckshit crazy thing in the first place
like she was trying to get me to just
come over and sit on her face or
whatever but then she was like uh you
know we'll have a we'll have a seance
and she's like don't worry we can talk
to the ghosts you know the hotels
haunted and she's like they're just
people that miss their homes
and that brought us to this moment and I
know that was like a long story but that
was the end of it I can't believe it all
right
Jameson that's just I mean what am I
gonna do yeah I wasn't I don't really
have to yeah but it's like that's like
me being like you know um you have to
hook up with top grade you gotta suck
them off dude yeah stop Brady not really
girls can do that and guys can't I mean
I just if I suck Tom Brady's dick that's
a lot different than if Jenna Jameson
goes down on you come on thank you I
mean
you say the wrong word for that moment
but I don't know what word I should
choose Thank you thank you you're
welcome
thank you for watching answer the
internet please remember to subscribe to
the channel set reminders with a little
bell comment who you want to see do it
and watch all the other answer the
internets I don't know where anything is
so I'm kind of just moving my hands
around but do all that [ __ ] subscribe
comment reminder watch others you're
welcome don't know why but you're
welcome